love him or hate him there's no denying
Quentin Tarantino is one of the most
influential directors of all time so it
goes without saying that many actors
would love to be in one of his movies
these however are the stars who passed
up that golden opportunity Michael
Madsen and Tarantino first met when the
actor auditioned for the role of mr.
pink in Reservoir Dogs
according to Madsen after doing his best
to land the gig Tarantino responded
you're not mr. pink you're mr. blonde
and if you're not mr. blonde then you're
not in the movie Madsen made the wise
decision and forever scarred moviegoers
with a straight razor and can of
gasoline and he evidently impressed
Tarantino since the autor wanted Madsen
to play pulp fiction's dancing hitman
Vincent Vega you know what they call
quarter panel cheese
Royalle wiedersehen unfortunately for
Madsen he'd already signed up the play
vigil earth in wyatt earp a western
starring kevin costner as the titular
lawman according to The Daily Beast it
took a long time for Tarantino to
forgive Matz and for turning down
Vincent Vega Madsen probably regretted
his choices well since pulp fiction is
widely hailed as one of the greatest
movies of all time
of course it was probably for the best
after all in hindsight it's hard to
imagine anyone other than John Travolta
playing the smarmy hit man plus if we'd
seen Michael Madsen dancing again we
probably would have suffered some pretty
traumatizing flashbacks
Warren Beatty is one of the most iconic
members of the Tinseltown elite and as
one of the biggest actors of the 60s and
70s he's appeared in some truly
memorable films for example there's
Bonnie and Clyde Reds and McCabe and
mrs. Miller but for all the great movies
he's worked on Beatty has turned down a
shocking number of classics as you might
have guessed Beatty also said no to
Quentin Tarantino so what role did
Tarantino offer Beatty well the director
wanted him to play the titular
antagonist and Kill Bill in fact he'd
written apart with Beatty in mind only
instead of creating the character as a
kung-fu killer he'd written a villain
who was a bit more suave and
sophisticated whom according to
Tarantino was quote much more of a James
Bond type of character tragically for
Tarantino baby wasn't interested in
shooting scenes in China preferring to
stay in the United States with his kids
however Beatty does take credit for the
casting of David Carradine claiming he
suggested Tarantino picked the martial
arts actor if so it was a genius
recommendation and Tarantino rewrote the
script so the character would be a
better fit you're not a bad person
yeah terrific person
my favorite people often forget that
Sylvester Stallone is a great actor
while the Razzies are happy to hurl
awards his way Stallone has more than
previous acting chops in movies like
rocky first blood
Copland and Crete as he made missteps
along the way more than a few but he's
also the guy who reminded Roger Ebert of
a young Marlon Brando in other words the
man has genuine talent and a spotty
track record which is the perfect type
of actor to star in a Tarantino movie
but life is cruel and we've never gotten
the Stallone Tarantino pairing we
deserve of course we shouldn't blame the
director for this travesty in an
interview with the Canadian magazine
McLane's Stallone revealed he was
offered not one but two roles in
separate Tarantino films according to
slide the director first asked if he
wanted to play the part of Luis a quiet
yet psychopathic thug in Jackie Brown
Stallone turned him down for undisclosed
reasons and the part of Gaara ended up
in Robert De Niro's more than capable
hands
undaunted Tarantino later offered
Stallone the death Proof part of
stuntman Mike McKay a serial killer who
dispatches of young women with a
specialized stunt car when Stallone
learned about those gory details
he told Tarantino he wasn't interested
explained to McLane's
I have two daughters and this fellow his
hobby is putting teenagers in his car
and smashing them into a wall that's not
going to work instead the part went to
Kurt Russell who after coming off movies
like miracle sky-high and dreamer this
is probably overjoyed to wreak a little
mayhem
or they get the benefit of an
imagine if you will a world where
Leonardo DiCaprio played Colonel Hans
Landa you can't can you
it's practically impossible to see
anyone other than Christoph Waltz
portraying the bingo loving monster but
according to MTV Tarantino originally
considered giving DiCaprio the part
before choosing to go with someone who
could speak German
Tarantino also thought about giving the
role of bridget von hammersmark to
Nastassja Kinski and he considered both
simon pegg and Tim Roth as possibilities
for the part of lieutenant Archie Hickox
however for one reason or another those
actors all fell by the wayside and the
roles went to Diane Kruger and Michael
Fassbender respectively but here's the
weirdest casting tidbit of all Once Upon
a Time
Tarantino wanted Adam Sandler for the
role of sergeant Donny Donowitz at first
glance the idea seems ridiculous but
despite movies like Jack and Jill
Sandler really is a skilled actor who
can do good work if he puts his mind to
it and if you've seen punch-drunk love
you know he can certainly smash a
restroom hoping Sandler would trade his
tire iron for a baseball bat Tarantino
made the character a Bostonian because
as he explained to Howard Stern Sandler
does a great Boston accent but alas
Sandler - Tarantino's dreams when he
signed on to do funny people instead the
part went to Eli Roth who did a bang-up
job if Adam Sandler can't beat up Bob
Barker then he probably isn't ready for
the Third Reich just yet I think you've
had enough no now you've had enough
you've probably heard that Will Smith
opted to stay on the sidelines when the
Wachowskis offered him the part of neo
in the matrix series but you might not
have known that when Tarantino came
calling
he couldn't convince the actor to say
yes either Tarantino wanted Smith to
play the part of Django in a spaghetti
western django unchained according to a
2015 interview with The Hollywood
Reporter Smith quote wanted to make that
movie so badly but he turned it down
because in his opinion it had to be a
love story not a vengeance story
violence begets violence
I just couldn't connect to violence
being the answer love had to be the
answer
certainly sounds nice and perhaps
Tarantino's penchant for bloodshed
really did affect Smith's decision but
if you go back to 2013 you'll see Smith
gave a very different excuse for why he
passed on Django Unchained according to
an interview with Entertainment Weekly
he turned down the role because it
wasn't big enough
he felt Christoph Waltz's dr. King
Schultz was actually the main character
especially since it's Schultz who shoots
the film's big bad guy this didn't sit
well with Smith who tried to convince
Tarantino to change things up as Smith
put it quote I was like no Quinton
please I need to kill the bad guy Jones
a little different than violence begets
violence a like the way you die
Will Smith wasn't the only major star to
turned down Django Unchained it seems
like every actor in Hollywood was
offered a part only to pass at the last
second for example Joseph gordon-levitt
was originally going to play a small
supporting role but left to work on his
directorial debut Don John
similarly RZA of the wu-tang clan was
meant to play a small part but had to
leave to edit his martial arts movie the
man with the iron fists according to
Indy wire so many actors were forced to
jump ship because filming on Django
Unchained went massively over schedule
in fact the movie took so long to make
that Tarantino was forced to scrap an
entire character originally the film was
supposed to feature a young man named
Scotty harmony a gambler who takes
possession of broom-hilda
Django's wife only to lose her to the
villainous Calvin Candie in a card game
the role was originally meant to be
played by Jonah Hill but just like RZA
and gordon-levitt
he was forced to drop out due to
scheduling conflicts will need to return
in a minor role for one of the funniest
scenes in Tarantino's whole filmography
anybody bring any extra bags no nobody
brought an extra bag
I'm just asking ultimately Tarantino
decided to go with Sacha Baron Cohen as
harmony which obviously meant the
character needed a bit of a rewrite
originally harmony was supposed to be
quote sexually inexperienced and naive
and Baron Cohen doesn't exactly fit that
bill but scheduling conflicts struck yet
again when the actor had to leave to
promote his upcoming film The Dictator
forced with setback after setback
Tarantino cut harmony out of the film
completely and unfortunately that wasn't
the only character who didn't make the
final draft in the original screenplay
for Django Unchained ace woody worked
directly under Calvin Candie as the guy
who taught slaves how to fight to the
death if woody had made it to the silver
screen there's no doubt we would have
witnessed some brutal acts of violence
as the screenplay has him tortured
Django but just like Scott eHarmony the
part of ACE woody wasn't meant to be
all because Tarantino couldn't keep an
actor around long enough to play the
part at first woody was supposed to be
played by Kevin Costner while he's been
in a handful of westerns
with wolves Silverado open range it's
not all that often Costner plays a
villain too bad he never got the chance
to go toe-to-toe with Jamie Foxx because
scheduling got in the way again
possibly due to projects like Hatfields
and McCoys as a result the part of woody
was given to Kurt Russell but the star
evidently got sick of how long it was
taking for tarantino to get anything
done allegedly Russell left the project
in frustration
once again Tarantino was forced to erase
one of his characters but since he had a
lot of good dialogue lying around he
decided to give those extra lines to
Billy crash the villain played by Walton
Goggins
and while Costner and Russell would have
been great as ace woody we really can't
complain the more Goggins the better
while Viggo Mortensen has committed his
fair share of on-screen bloodshed be it
against orcs and Lord of the Rings or
mobsters and Eastern Promises somehow
the actor and Tarantino have never
gotten together though it's not for lack
of trying
in an interview with Grantland Mortensen
revealed he actually auditioned for two
parts in Reservoir Dogs and while he
doesn't remember which roles he tried
out for he did try to play one as
Hispanic Tarantino decided to pass on
the actor but a few years later the
situation was reversed this time the
director was interested in having
Mortensen play quote a ruthless gang
leader in the hateful eight as there's
only one gang leader in the film it's
safe to assume Tarantino wanted
Mortensen to play the ruthless Jodie
Dahmer Guu unfortunately Mortensen had
to skip on the French lessons as he was
busy promoting two smaller films he'd
recently made how huh and far from men
Mortensen told Grantland I knew as a
producer and an actor that I needed to
do that for those movies to have a
chance to be seen Tarantino wanted to
start shooting at the end of the year
and do rehearsal before that and I just
couldn't do that schedule wise the role
eventually went to Channing Tatum and
the actor pulled it off with psychotic
charm to spare if you
was it cat what just happened here what
comes one of your nine lives when
writing the screenplay for the hateful
eight tarantino had an actor in mind for
every single character except two he
wasn't sure who would play Bob though
the role went to Demi and Bachir and he
didn't know who was going to play the
female lead
Daisy Dahmer gue while pondering his
predicament Tarantino considered
Jennifer Lawrence for the part and he
even met with the actress to discuss the
possibility of her squaring off against
samuel l.jackson however as Tarantino
explained lawrence was working on joy
and promoting the Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 2 in other words she was
swamped and couldn't spare any time
while he was probably disappointed at
first Tarantino eventually decided
warrants probably wasn't right for the
part he told Entertainment Weekly I'm
glad I didn't cast somebody that young I
think I absolutely positively made the
right choice as far as the ages of the
characters instead the director went
with an older actress 53 year old
Jennifer Jason Leigh who earned an Oscar
nod for her sinister performance as the
calculating outlaw check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]